If you look at
what's known as the procession of the equinox,
there is a wobble of the earth
that faces different constellations
during this 26,000 year cycle known as the Great Year.
What we find is that they're these cycles
built into that cycle.
Yes. Where these catastrophes seem to happen.
I don't think that's by accident.
Right. Where you have many cycles within the big cycle.
Yes. If you were to create an environment where
you could have these beings,
it's almost like a game.
Imagine if you were these omnipotent beings
and everything to you is like games.
To the idea of how far can a conscious being get
in a certain amount of time,
and if it doesn't,
it has to start over again.
How far can it get in that next cycle?
Seems to be
exactly what's playing out here is that we have 12,
maybe sometimes 24,000 years
depending on.
On what you we look at geologically.
But there are these cyclical events that seem to
reoccurring on this basis
where we only get a certain amount of time to say, see,
how far can you get?
And then you got to start over again.
Seems to be like a game.
Yeah. Not a pleasant one.